bonjour à tous donc d'abord nos
premières pensées début de presse vont
aux victimes de la catastrophe
au tiers de puisseguin et républicains
adresse à l'ensemble des familles leurs
plus sincères condoléances
alors en ce qui concerne l'agenda
donc nous sommes toujours en les
vacances scolaires donc il n'y aura ni
bureau politique ni comment commission
exécutive
par contre je dis 9 octobre
nicolas sarkozy se rendra à moscou
accompagnée d'une délégation de
parlementaires donc sont au programme et
une rencontre avec vladimir poutine
dans la matinée nicolas sarkozy
s'exprimera devant les étudiants de
l'université m guinot qui est l'une des
plus prestigieuses universités russes
il rencontrera également des
représentants d'entreprises françaises
pendant qu'une délégation de
parlementaires ira à la douma pour un
certain nombre d'entretiens et le soir
nicolas sarkozy rencontrera les des
français expatriés républicain donc en
russie un petit mot tout de suite sur le
mardi 3 novembre où nous allons faire
notre journée de travail sur la sécurité
cette journée de travail était
programmée depuis déjà un petit moment
mais le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est
qu'elle sera vraiment d'actualité avec
la fusillade qui encore eu lieu ce
week-end à marseille avec les événements
de moirans
véritablement il y a nécessité de faire
des propositions fortes en matière de
sécurité et nous rappelons que quand
nicolas sarkozy était président de la
république
la courbe de la délinquance était
résolument orienté à la baisse et depuis
que françois hollande est président de
la république
malheureusement nous avons à déplorer
une courbe de la délinquance qui remonte
de manière régulière
alors aujourd'hui le gouvernement se
déplace en banlieue aux mureaux
finalement c'est une tentative un peu
vaine de faire oublier le pitoyable
déplacement à la courneuve ou françois
hollande a été reçu par par les huées et
et c'est vrai que le mépris de la gauche
et du gouvernement à l'endroit des
banlieues et des quartiers populaires et
de plus en plus fort et les habitants de
ces quartiers l'ont très bien compris et
c'est pour cela qu'ils ont très
fortement sanctionné le gouvernement
lors des différentes élections
cette sanction s'est illustré avec les
scrutins par exemple clichy la garenne
aulnay sous bois ou noisy-le-sec des
villes de banlieues des villes
populaires qui sont passés de la gauche
vers la droite
donc la vérité c'est que la gauche n'a
strictement rien fait pour les banlieues
depuis 2012 et la gauche veut tout
simplement à travers ses déplacements
faire de la retape auprès de cet
électorat à l'électorat de banlieue et
tombe dans un espèce de d'automatismes
qui est qui et le clientélisme
car il considère que ces populations
voteront systématiquement à gauche
puisqu'elles sont dans des quartiers
populaires sauf que ces populations
connaissent les mêmes difficultés que
l'ensemble des français à savoir une
hausse du chômage la délinquance qui est
de plus en plus forte l'insécurité qui
est de plus en plus
importante et le communautarisme
galopant donc ils sanctionnent le bilan
de ce gouvernement
il refuse d'être instrumentalisés et
c'est vrai que la droite un bilan qui
est beaucoup a fait beaucoup plus de
choses pour pour pour les banlieues
rappelant les 43 milliards d'euros de
l'anru entre 2003 et il me semble 2000
jusqu'à la fin du 2012 oui donc voilà ce
qu'il faut dans les banlieues
aujourd'hui c'est pas des opérations de
communication
c'est vraiment que l'autorité de l'état
et l'ordre républicain reviennent
d'urgence ces quartiers fou et doivent à
nouveau faire partie de la république et
il faut stopper la spirale infernale de
la délinquance les événements de
marseille nous le rappelle encore il
faut également faire revenir je dirais
la craie blanche du savoir dans ces
quartiers donc à mon sens il est assez
vent pour le gouvernement d'aller faire
autant de retape et de tenter de faire
une opération de séduction auprès auprès
de ces quartiers de cet électorat
ils ne sont absolument pas dupes du
bilan a dû du gouvernement
la question que nous pouvons nous poser
également sur ce déplacement c'est dans
cette compétition qui ne dit pas son nom
entre françois hollande et manuel valls
si manuel valls ne peut ne veut pas
aujourd'hui démontré que lui peut se
déplacer en banlieue sans être l'objet
de huées ou de siffler comme l'a été la
semaine dernière françois hollande
je change de sujet est pour quelque
chose qui est beaucoup moins
diplomatique si je puis dire c'est que
nous avons eu droit aussi ce week-end 1
laurent fabius qui a été fort peu
diplomatique les termes peu amènes c'est
moins qu'on puisse dire de monsieur
fabius vis-à-vis de nicolas sarkozy de
l'ancien président de la république nous
font dire que nous pourrions attendre du
chef de la diplomatie qu'il le fasse
preuve d'un peu plus d'élégance vie
david un ancien président de la
république française monsieur fabius est
d'autant plus mal placés pour tenir les
propos qu'il a pu
vis-à-vis de nicolas sarkozy parlait des
résultats du front national que monsieur
fabius et le premier ministre qui a
instauré la proportionnelle pour les
élections législatives qui a permis à
une trentaine de députés front national
de faire leur entrée au palais bourbon
donc nous amenons nous nous demandons à
monsieur fabius de faire preuve à la
fois de plus d'élégance et de plus
d'humidité